Let's just say like, I don't know, let's just say that health rose over and
they're like, Google becomes allergic to money from agencies and they're like,
ah, we're not going to accept that shit.
Okay.
Guess what we're going to do?
We're going to just use a different fricking ad platform.
It, the Google ads is the, is the technique, the strategy is
results in advance, right?
So like, that's not, that's not the end all be all.
We were, it's just an easy way to feed them leads, but guess what?
If that goes away, we'll spend our money somewhere else.
You know, we'll figure it out.
So obviously that we don't want that to be the case, but like, I'm never
going to lose sleep because I'm a problem solver.